hey what's up everyone it's Warren and
in the past couple of days we've gotten
a lot of information that confirms some
major plot points about Avengers in game
and we got this information directly
from Marvel and the Russo brothers
themselves so official information to go
over and break down in this video real
quick if you're not aware I started a
new giveaway I'm giving away five imax
tickets so you and some friends can go
see Avengers in-game and IMAX if you'd
like to enter for your chance to win all
you have to do subscribe to my channel
like the video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
character that could be a superhero or a
villain so marketing for Avengers in
game is about to take off into full
swing we have a teaser trailer that we
got back in December and with the
Superbowl that's come we got a brand new
TV spot that had all new footage in it
and now we have an official image from
Marvel themselves now it is a
promotional photo so it is Photoshop but
nonetheless it doesn't really matter
because again it comes directly from
Marvel and we get to see a new look at
some of the characters new costumes now
right off the bat you can tell these are
the original six Avengers and there's
only major changes for three of them as
you can tell for Black Widow and Hawkeye
look the same Hawkeye is wearing his
ronin armor you can see it on his legs
there black widow has red Harrigan and
Thor looks the same but Captain America
has on his classic scale armor now we've
seen this before in concept art and
promo photos but this is the first time
that we really get a full look at it and
it looks really awesome and then we have
Iron Man who has a new Iron Man suit so
this confirms what everybody has been
calling the mark 85 armor and as you can
tell if you look really closely there's
a lot more gold to this armor and that
is because this armor is sort of a
tribute to some of the original Iron Man
armors that Iron Man wore in the comics
we've had some leaks and heard some
rumors that Iron Man will in fact get
the mark 85 armor and Avengers in game
but now it is officially confirmed by
this promo photo that has been released
by Marvel and then the biggest reveal of
all that comes from this photo is
Professor Hulk this is the first time
that we're actually seeing the Hulk
that's not concept art and as you can
see if you take a close
it's definitely Bruce banners face this
is because professor Hulk is sort of a
perfect version of the Hulk it's the
Hulk's body with Bruce banners mind so
instead of having two different people
Bruce Banner and the Hulk they're merged
together as one when the first concept
art came out for Avengers in game we
noticed that the Hulk's face kind of
looked a little bit more like Bruce
Banner but now with this official photo
from Marvel zine Bruce banners face on
the Hulk's body confirms professor Hulk
but perhaps the biggest reveal of this
photo is on black widows left hand as
you can see she's wearing one of the
bracelets that some of the Avengers were
wearing and some leaked set photos for
Avengers in game and on many different
leaks and concept art photos that we
have for the movie these bracelets are
widely believed to be for traveling
inside of the quantum realm which the
Avengers will use to travel back in time
to try and change events so that they
can defeat Thanos and this is the first
official confirmation that we've gotten
from Marvel that the Avengers will in
fact wear these bracelets another thing
that happened a couple of days ago is
the Russo brothers had an interview with
Collider during the interview Collider
Steve Weintraub asked the Russo brothers
about the recent toy leaks in which Joe
Russo replied what's interesting about
toy leaks is that 99% of the time
they're not accurate because toys are
frankly tailored to either old concepts
or completely different concepts than
what's in the movie he continued to say
that I laugh a lot when those toy leaks
show up because I'm like well that's
great because that's a misdirect because
it has nothing to do with the film now I
want to point out a few things here for
starters he never really said the toy
leaks aren't real what he said was 99%
of the time they're not accurate that
could mean a lot of different things
we've had so many toilets and leaked
concept art by now and they all look
exactly the same
so maybe what Joe Russo means is that in
the movie they actually look a little
bit different because he never came out
and said they're not real he just said
that they're not accurate and another
thing to keep in mind is that they're
trying to keep everything about Avengers
in game as secretive as possible there's
no way he'd come out and say oh yeah
they're totally real instead he just
sort of dances around the question a
little bit by saying they're not
accurate and another thing to keep in
mind is this is the same guy that came
out and said that
idle of Avengers four is not a vengers
in-game Andy even went on to say that
the title has never been mentioned
before in any of the movies and I'm not
saying it's bad I think it's really good
he's doing this so everything can be a
surprise to us so I think by him saying
that the toy leaks aren't necessarily
100 percent accurate is him saying yes
they're real they just may not look
exactly the same in the movie because
we've already seen merchandise that
looks like the quantum realm suits which
actually don't look 100% accurate to the
old concept art that we got in the
beginning which showed the Avengers
wearing basically all-white quantum
realm suits the hoodie has a lot more
orange and black to it so although the
quantum realm suits may not look a
hundred percent just like the concept
art photos I do think we'll be seeing
them in Avengers in game so that's it
for all the latest news concerning
Avengers endgame let me know your
thoughts on the promo photo that was
released and let me know your thoughts
about what Joe Russo said in the
interview with Collider let me know your
thoughts in the comments down below and
again don't forget to subscribe comment
and like the video so you can enter the
giveaway and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers in game
as always thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]